à ses moments perdus ils arrivent à
françois bovy habitants de l'oise
passionné d'histoire de jouets de la
viole un témoignage musical qui se
double d'une autre recherches sur le
passé
la quête des survivances orale la
recherche du parler picard
c'est tout le message de quelques
terroir fils soit tu te rendre ainsi à
notre compréhension
aussi va-t-il régulièrement de
chaumières en village pour recueillir
les expressions simplement muni d'un
bloc-notes et d'un crayon
ainsi dans cette ferme de la neuville
vaut à quelques kilomètres de beauvais
au confluent des influences normandes et
picardes
dans certaines familles les expressions
d'antan sont bien restés ancrés dans les
esprits et pour se mettre à l'abri à
l'abri des intempéries
avant je me rendors ans mourad aux
anneaux c'est si on est ici on est à
l'extérieur en plein par exemple mais on
va doullens allume la chose à un viol la
rieuse et un talus à dos et là on peut
mettre une chose aussi à la mort ne peut
pas remettre soudain pris la direction
de poser des gens oui du divan à
l'oreille mais oui par exemple vieillard
beyond de france bédard
monsieur possède est ce qu'il vous
arrive encore de parler picard entre
vous très rarement parce qu'ici il n'y a
pas beaucoup de picards des yeux piquent
à elle n'a pas un sou finale est-ce que
vous parlez tout de même un peu en
famille non on ne parle presque publics
n'ont pas pu piquer ya il ya un mode
picard qui viendra dans une conversation
mais en fait on ne parle pas picard
comprenez vous
on n'a pas une conversation au pis car
il par pika inconsciemment un mot dans
une phrase diront inquiétant à ouï dire
inquiétant que en français on dirait
qu'elle temps diront c'est un oui mais
pas vous dire aux titans 1
mais gardons comme ça dans une phase
mais par le papy tard est ce que vous
trouvez que le pic à est une belle
langue
oh oui c'est une langue qui voit là
aussi bien pour la province picarde que
pour n'importe quelle autre province
monsieur je ne vois pas pourquoi vous
parlez pas picard à 87 ans pierre
possède n'a décidément pas perdu son
picard et s'il a de moins en moins
l'occasion de le parler
il peut encore très bien nous réciter
quelques poésies faire encore quelques
vers du poète amoureux d'une vidéo par
exemple
par exemple at-il un éclairage point de
vue quand je suis pour ie il est tout
seul tout ce je crois que fut tant que
le pauvre mère l'habitude on n'a tout de
même rien value d'acheteurs il reste
plus que le camp busca la taxe à matisse
usa je crois que fut ce vous recensez de
parler picard en prenant des notes est
ce que cela suffit pour perpétuer les
expressions fidèlement oui je pense pour
l'avenir ces expressions sont conservés
fidèlement puisque je j'écris tout en
phonétique et on peut dire que pour le
pays
ce sera pratiquement perdu mais pour les
spécialistes ce sera très intéressant de
retrouver l'expression telle qu'elle
était
[Musique]